with only a couple of months to go until
the film's release Disney tantalized
Star Wars fans with a new trailer for
the latest chapter in the Skywalker saga
Star Wars the last Jedi according to
director Rian Johnson fans who want to
go in completely clean might actually
want to skip watching the trailer but if
potential spoilers hold no power over
you let's take a look at what you might
have missed in the last Jedi's new
trailer Luke's biggest fear the trailer
picks up where the force awakens left
off on the planet octave as Rey hands
Luke the lightsaber that was once
wielded by his father Darth Vader
we then see Rey training with the weapon
as Luke locks on and it soon becomes
clear just how innately talented she is
Skywalker looks positively shocked as
the ground cracks open while Rey
meditates and as clear is having
flashbacks to what happened with his
last protege his nephew Ben solo who now
serves Supreme Leader Snoke under the
name kylo Ren it's then that Luke
reveals he's actually afraid of Rey's
talents just as we get a more detailed
look at the aftermath of the attack on
luke's jedi temple by kylo and the
knights of ren
he's clearly reluctant to train her lest
she turned to the dark side
Ray's journey while it's clear that Rey
spend some time with Luke on up to she's
not going to always be on the water's
edge she's also shown approaching what
looks like a burn tree trunk in a rocky
landscape and looking down at a book
inside Luke's force-sensitive treehouse
in the previous teaser she was browsing
what many believe is the fabled journey
of the Welsh which means Rey is about to
get a lesson in the origins of the force
and the Jedi Order from a new teacher
later we see a drench to Luke looking up
and saying this is not going to go the
way you think considering we also see
Rey diving under the water near what
looks like a fantasy monster it might go
exactly like we think it will that shot
directly aligns with rumors that the
native ports of arc 2 will demands that
Rey Slayer fearsome sea monster in order
to stay on the planet kylos moment of
truth you may have noticed the space
battle shots featuring a new version of
the classic TIE fighter
this is kylo Ren's personal craft and
it's called the tie silencer it's
supposed to be sort of like the original
trilogy's tie interceptor and comes
equipped with laser cannons and missile
launchers in this battle sequence it
appears that kylo Ren is
setting his sights on a Mon Calamari
star cruiser and since general Leia
Organa is shown sitting down on the
bridge the implication of the cutaways
between layers face and the suns are
clear
each knows the other is there and the
banners the opportunity to deal a
gigantic blow to the resistance by
destroying the ship and ending the life
of his mother now for the big question
will he or won't he pull the trigger
Finn's weapon in one major spoiler given
away by the trailer we see that finn has
clearly recovered from the wounds he
sustained during the force awakens and
is back in fighting shape before a duel
against Captain phasma phasma wields a
force pike while finn is carrying a riot
control baton much like the one
previously carried by the stormtrooper
he fought during the battle on takodana
in the force awakens we also couldn't
help but notice Finn's first-order
officer's uniform and the following
scene as he walked somewhere escorted by
stormtroopers in case he missed it he a
new character Rose dawn those uniforms
and behind-the-scenes footage that made
its way online so since the background
behind Finn and phasma in the duel looks
a lot like the destroyed remnants of the
first order this duel might possibly
take place after a secret infiltration
and sabotage mission by Finn and Rose
new creatures in addition to the
previously mentioned pogs the last Jedi
is set to introduce a whole bunch of new
additions to the Star Wars universe
while we didn't see them in the trailer
Entertainment Weekly broke the news in
August 2017 at Octus residents include a
group of none like creatures known only
as the caretakers but the trailer did
feature one exciting shot of another new
species for crystalline fox-like animals
which reside on the mineral world of
crate the Battle of crate it seems clear
from the new trailer and all of the
other footage released thus far that the
land battle on crate will play a major
role in the last Jedi the new trailer
gives us our first good look at the
massive firepower that the first order
will bring to bear against the
resistance on the surface of the planet
those in place of the regular old
Imperial walkers are the new and
improved a tm6 walkers one can only hope
that these machines are just as
susceptible to proton bombs harpoons and
tow cables as our older cousins all the
resistance may really be in some trouble
snoke's identity if the trailer doesn't
actually give away snow's identity but
does reveal a big clue leading up to the
final moments of the trailer we hear
Snoke apparently telling race she needs
to fulfill your destiny and it looks
like he's using his powers to torture
her this could also mean that snoke's
voiceover from the beginning of the
trailer where he talks about someone's
raw untamed power could be directed
array and not kylo Ren instead of a
30-foot tall hologram in the force
awakens this is Snoke in the flesh and
his flesh appears to be distinctly
humanoid but seems to blow the Snoke is
Darth Plagueis Theory out of the water
since he was an alien and that also
apparently debunks the Snoke is Grand
Moff Tarkin theory since Snoke seems
able to use the Force while Tarkin
couldn't as for how he got ahold of Rey
to begin with well consider the rumors
like kylo will attack Luke and rayon op
2 and it seems possible that kylo ends
up abducting Rey from the planet and
taking her back to his master the
Millennium Falcon soars again
in a couple of short clips from the new
last Jedi trailer we see the Millennium
Falcon back in action at diving and
twisting through what appears to be an
underground labyrinth based on the red
crystals we can see it seems likely that
the dogfight happens in a cave somewhere
one crate and a notice how the poor
gantu Bakr are shown together on the
ship but we don't see who's in the pilot
seat
if kylo abducts Rey this could spur Luke
who's not such a bad pilot himself to
join Chewie and return to his sister
lair to help her take on the first order
pose fire in our first glimpse of Poe
Dameron from the trailer he's aboard
what appears to be some sort of Mon
Calamari lifeboat which could point to
the star cruiser we saw previously
getting hit and the promises to
he hops in his x-wing which appears to
have been retrofitted with some sort of
afterburner as he dives and spins in an
attack run on the first order
dreadnought looming over crate frenemies
last but not least there's that
seemingly friendly exchange between
waiting kylo this may be some editing
misdirection but it sure looks like Rey
is telling kylo she needs some advice
this clip of Rey could come from when
she tries to persuade Luke to trainer
but the clip of kylo Ren is more elusive
he has a scar so it can't be a flashback
to when he destroyed Luke's temple
additionally he's no longer wearing the
bandage we've seen in earlier clips this
could suggest that the clip comes from
near the end of the movie but who could
kylo be extending his hand to it's a
clip that neatly echoes the visuals of
the scene between Han and his son so
could kylo be possibly accepting
Redemption from the hands of his mother
or his uncle or is it another
double-cross thankfully we won't have to
wait much longer to find out thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're loved too
[Music]